[Musique]
mon
je m'appelle ranger le coup ça je suis
fondateur et développeur chez le coussin
médias
[Musique]
du coup sa meilleure aujourd'hui c'est
une agence digitale
nous accompagnons toutes les entreprises
et même les particuliers aussi dans leur
parcours numérique on a plusieurs pages
dans nos services qu'on propose aux
entreprises et des packs de création
d'identités visuelles jusqu'à la
conception du site internet de même de
l'application mobile
tout dépend de la demande du client et
nous sommes là pour les accompagner dans
leurs projets leurs et d adidas
végétalisée
[Musique]
j'ai un peu question ça a été si j'ai et
après je voulais continuer les études
mais chercher d'alternance et j'ai pas
trouvé alternance du coup je me suis
dirigé vers une formation développeurs
check up et après ça je me suis dit vu
que les alternances est compliqué à
avoir parce qu'une femme d'expérience on
va se réappropriant seul pour la
formation de société et pour l'argent je
me suis rapproché de toon books
tout est parti de son personnel
[Musique]
le but c'était pas vraiment de cet
épatant de temps ça de faire du chiffre
c'était plus pouvoir aider les autres à
faire du chiffre et plus on aide les
gens et musées clients cherchent à se
démarquer sur le numérique parce qu'être
le coc vide on sait que c'est compliqué
de vendre comme ça physiquement et
cherchent plutôt l'évasion numérique
pour les aider
mon